nice to see you good to see you rachel
it's been a long time i know
life's treating you well life's great i
mean i'd say so mister you got a lot
going on right now you got presenting
duties this evening at the vm mesa place
you know very well i'm presenting and uh
you're taking care you're holding down
the fort when it comes to this revival
going on with inkmasters right i'm
bringing ink masters back i'm excited
about it you know i love tattoos so and
i've been a fan of the show you love
tattoos a little bit
i have a couple and i'm a big fan of the
show i've watched every season so to do
the show was really fun for me
and um yeah it's great now from my
understanding so dave navarro was a
former host you guys are doing a
revamped kind of version and spin on it
but is dave still going to be involved
in the mix dave's still involved he's
the master of chaos
imagine that he's he's all over the show
to be honest anybody who loves dave's
still going to be happy because dave is
still yeah all over the place how do you
hope that you're putting your mark on
the show uh
you know what i like to have fun i'm
serious about tattoos but not so serious
about lots of other things so i've got a
lot of dad jokes so
i feel like it's a good
it's a good energy to bring to the
tattoo world well you know what
family friendly tattoo guy nicole is
digging this energy that you're going to
be bringing to inkmasters i do believe
she says
when you said that you were going to be
a part of the show she said that she was
proud and horny yes she was proud and
horny that's why that's my wife
do you think lionel lionel didn't see it
he didn't see it
i did not get a text all right so you
and nicole are now both
a part of competition reality shows yes
highly competitive making the cut i'm on
ink masters i know i know but is are
things highly competitive at home now
our our family is a competition show so
our kids have to compete for our love so
um it's really healthy for them it's
good so healthy yeah but which kind of
leads me to would you guys ever do a
reality show on your family bring the
cameras into your home
uh no
nicole's done it before nicole you know
many years ago she had that show you
know that show
i don't know you know maybe maybe not
probably not probably not yeah my kids
are not they're not down yeah yeah
you'd be giving us dad jokes left and
right they would be so embarrassed if we
had if we were on a show together they'd
be embarrassed i love it you look great
tonight did nicole pick this out for you
uh
more or less more or less she signs off
on everything that's you need to make
sure you make that happen yeah
[Music]